Guten Morgen Linus.
Guten Morgen Tim.
Sag mal, warum bin ich eigentlich immer nicht dabei, wenn's so richtig interessant wird? Linus.
Lockbuch Netzpolitik, Folge einhundertneunundvierzig, ich bin zu Gast im Zentrum des Landesverrats bei Markus Beckerdal.
Guten Morgen.
Und Andre Meister.
Guten Morgen Deutschland.
Markus, du hast gestern einen schönen Brief bekommen, der jetzt inzwischen die komplette äh Startseite der Tagesschau beschäftigt. Was stand denn dadrin?
Gestern Mittag äh wurde mir zu Hause eine förmliche Zustellung äh des Generalbundesanwalts zugestellt, wo wir heraus erfahren haben, dass gegen Andre mich und äh eine Person namens Unbekannt, die wir in unserem Redaktion
verzeichnest nicht finden konnten. Jetzt wegen Landesverrats ermittelt wird,
ja, wer muss da auch immer nachgucken, was das so genau bedeutet? Das kann ich noch irgendwie aus Geschichtsbüchern, Landesverrat, da stellte man sich irgendwie,
keine Ahnung wie Uhr. Ähm die Uhrgeschichte der Demokratie vor, die noch bedroht war und
Ja und waren dann auf einmal ein bisschen irritiert, dass der Staat anscheinend mit dem schärfsten Geschütz, was ihm zur Verfügung steht, ging unser kleines Block schießt.
Natürlich erstmal online gestellt.
Wir haben vor zwei Folgen mit mit André darüber gesprochen, als bekannt wurde, dass überhaupt ermittelt wird. Das ist ja schon ungefähr zwei Wochen her. Da musstest du erstmal nochmal im im Archiv von Netzwerk org schauen, ob äh ob ihr da mit gemeint seid?
Ja, das war, das war total super, da stehe ich so samstags morgens auf und äh kriege auf Twitter irgendwas
äh ist da über Deutschlandfunk irgendwas äh passiert, war von einem Internetdienst die Rede, ohne uns namentlich zu nennen und von zwei Veröffentlichungen aus Monaten, wo wo mir schon irgendwas so schwante und dann
kurz irgendwie nachgeguckt, ob die Geschichten zum Verfassungsschutz, die ich so gerade im Kopf hatte, irgendwie auch in den Monaten waren und stellte halt fest, oh, damit sind wir wohl gemeint,
See gefahren. Nachdem ich das natürlich geblockt hatte.
Wie ist denn jetzt also,
wie ist denn das Gefühl? Also mal ganz ehrlich so, wir haben natürlich wenn man nicht selber in in diesen äh Schuhen steckt, dann denkt man sich natürlich so über was für ein großartiger Ritterschlag für die Redaktion, was für eine tolle Auszeichnung für eure Arbeit.
Aber ähm das Strafmaß ist, glaube ich, mindestens ein Jahr. In schweren Fällen geht's irgendwie hoch bis lebenslänglich. Ähm.
Fühlst du dich da, äh fühlt ihr euch da jetzt ernsthaft bedroht?
Na ja sagen wir mal so, also wenn sich so mit ganz vielen Journalisten unterhält, die Hälfte ist
Also alles in Anteils äh nehmen Anteil und so weiter, riesige Solidarität äh äh aber die Hälfte denkt echt äh irgendwie so ein bisschen so äh ist ein bisschen neidisch, hätte ich auch gern und denke, wir tanzen ja auf den Tischen, weil uns kann nichts passieren, aber man kriegt zu den,
eigentlich die größte Auszeichnung, die irgendwie ein Journalist in Deutschland bekommen kann, ähm nämlich,
ja, quasi äh Anzeige oder Ermittlungen wegen Landesfacharzt. Das hat bisher nur der Augstein eigentlich so richtig geschafft.
Und die konkrete Now hier ja irgendwie dreiundachtzig habe ich eben gelernt, äh aber,
also es gab so einen Moment gestern, der das vielleicht so äh illustrierter als meine Mutter irgendwie ähm Videotexco
und auf einmal irgendwie die Meldung bei der ARD last, dass äh bis zu Lebensdenklich mir droht und ich erstmal am Telefon meine Mutter beruhigen musste, ne, äh seit ähm wahrscheinlich nicht der Fall sein wird und wenn, dann könnte sie stolz auf mich sein,
das ist eigentlich schon so ein komisches Gefühl, weil ich meine ähm,
Ja, also sagen wir bis gestern Mittag hatte ich, äh wusste ich gar nicht, dass man in Deutschland für investigative journalistische Arbeit und für das, was wir machen, überhaupt in den Knast kommen kann, also äh also schon psyrial.
Andre, wie blickst du auf die Sache?
Um die Frage, die du Markus gerade gestellt hast, auch nochmal zu beantworten. Äh heute Morgen hat mich jemand gefragt, also wie es viele Leute so tun und wie fühlst du dich gerade alles in Ordnung? Und ich so
Na ja, also im letzten Jahr haben wir ja jetzt nicht gerade wenigen Autoritäten auf die Finger geklopft und haben,
Bundeskanzlerin, BND, BKA, des BKA, mir sogar angezeigt, ähm, Berliner Polizei,
gestern haben wir die Bundeswehr Verteidigungsministerium liegt dazu gemacht also dass wir jetzt irgendwie.
Uneingreifbar sind, unverwundbar sind. Das haben wir natürlich nie gedacht. Ähm aber
jetzt auch mit dem Medienecho gestern nach dem Brief war meine Reaktion nur für wie fühlst du dich eher so oder? Also ist jetzt eigentlich auch nicht anders als vor zwei Tagen,
als vor der DLF-Meldung, wo wir es gehört haben. Ähm jetzt wo wir es schriftlich haben, ist halt schon echt krass zu hören,
aber ist ja nicht so, dass wir naiv sind und nicht wüssten, dass einige Institutionen gibt,
die durchaus Interesse an unserer Telefonkommunikation, E-Mail, Kommunikation äh oder auch ähm Stories, die wir bringen könnten und äh Quellen, die wir haben, interessiert sind,
aber als ich dann so gesagt habe, ja ist ja eigentlich enorme Auffakt, kam dann ah, du bist noch in der Leugnungsphase, in der ersten Phase,
Ist tatsächlich nicht ohne äh für Landesfahrrad, wenn es denn eine Verurteilung gäbe, was ich für ziemlich unwahrscheinlich halte,
aber es steht tatsächlich äh mindestens ein Jahr Knast
pro Fall. Wir sind ja in zwei Fällen angezeigt. Und eben ist nach oben offen die Skala und wir sind irgendwie nicht nur Zeugen, was wir eigentlich gedacht haben, weil Pressefreiheit ist ja geschützt, sondern als sogenannte Mit.
Angeklagt und das ist schon echt harter Tobak, wo man schon mal kurz innehalten äh kann und sich
vergegenwärtigen kann. Das geht jetzt zwar net durchs Internet und äh fahren Solidarität, aber eigentlich kann das bedeuten, dass man selbst für lange Zeit im
Bau sitzt und das will man eigentlich nicht und das ist total hanebüchen für die Berichterstattung, die wir machen, weil wir tun eigentlich nur unseren Job.
Ich denke auch ähm,
Das wird ja da wird ja jetzt nicht irgendjemand so durchs Internet geklickt haben und gesagt haben, oh, was ist das denn hier für eine Seite? Ähm Maaßen kommen wir, wir zeigen die mal an, sondern es zeigt ja auch wirklich, welches Interesse von diesen Stellen
an eurer Tätigkeit schon lange herrschen muss, ne? Also die werden sicher schon länger mit euch auseinandersetzen. Wie ihr ja auch mit ihnen, das scheint so eine.
Gegenseitige Koexistenz da zu sein.
Die Institutionen haben natürlich auch Pressemonitoring, was über sie so geschrieben und veröffentlicht wird. Äh wir kriegen das jeden Morgen aufbereitet. Und tatsächlich habe ich ja schon vor zwei Wochen im letzten Podcast gesagt, also mir war mir war klar, in dem Moment, als ich
veröffentlichen klicke bei dem Artikel, dass der VS Präsident jetzt nicht gerade Freudentänze aufführt,
Aber das ist auch nicht unsere Aufgabe. Unsere Aufgabe ist es eben, äh für äh der öffentliche Diskussion unseren Teil beizutragen und Informationen, die öffentlich relevant sind, äh auch zu veröffentlichen. Gerade Posts unten.
Die ganzen Telefonnummern von Anwälten, die hier an jeder Wand hängen, die hingen hier schon vorher, aber da habt ihr die.
Das sind nur äh zwei Zettel von Anwälten und die hängen hier seit einigen Wochen.
Genau, der haben wir auch schon den anderen Mitarbeitern, die etwas früher als wir kommen, ähm übergeben, weil äh man hört ja immer, dass irgendwie solche Durchsuchungen zu äh undankbaren Zeiten.
Wo du gar nicht hier bist.
Noch schlafen.
Genau.
Morgens um sechs oder im Sommer sogar um fünf oder so ein Mist.
Und ähm
Was ich sehr schön finde, ihr habt diese Mitteilung über die Ermittlungen gegen euch direkt ähm gerahmt und zu dem Lead-Award, dem Grimma-Online-Award, der Auszeichnung als Journalist des Jahres zweitausendvierzehn und der Auszeichnung
ausgezeichneter Ort zweitausendfünfzehn in Deutschland Land der Ideen aufgehängt? Ist das Geigenhumor oder empfindet ihr das jetzt schon irgendwie auch als Auszeichnung für eure Arbeit?
Alle schreiben dort, das ist der Ritterschlag, ähm den man so bekommen kann, also das klingt so, als wäre das so der größte Journalisten Award, den die Bundesrepublik zu vergeben hat. Bei gab's erst dreimal oder also vor uns zweimal,
und,
Ja, wenn äh so viele irgendwie äh neidisch sind, dass wir dann bekommen und sie nicht, dann muss man das wohl einrahmen. Außerdem hatten wir Sorgen, äh dass wenn wir nicht einen Ramen, dass der Zettel irgendwie.
Ey hier.
Papiermüll.
Sorge ist nicht unbekannt.
Möchte ich auch echt nicht sein, der hier Markus Schreibtisch durchsuchen darf oder auch,
das Foto auf, was war das heute, das heute im Spiel, Druckspiegel ist äh von unserem Office analysieren darf, weil das ist ja, was die machen, die hören dann diesen Podcast und die äh äh gelesen unsere Interviews und die versuchen daraus Erkenntnisse zu gewinnen.
Viel Spaß mit dem Wimmelbildern.
Die ich echt nicht sagen. Aber du hast jetzt.
Müssen, meinst du, die müssen erst transkribieren?
Weiß ich nicht, aber wenn, dann könnten die das bitte gleich äh für alle machen. Ich hätte dann auch gerne einen Transkript.
Wer das schreibt ist doof.
IFG-Anfrage stellen.
Der Typ, der bei der Gamer die Titel eingibt.
Egal. Äh musste einfach mal eine IFG-Anfrage für das Transkript darstellen.
Laufende Ermittlungen.
Ich habe ja hier ähm bei euch liegt ja auch alles voll mit diesen förmlichen Zustellungen, ne. Also das sind eigentlich das sind gelbe Umschläge von der deutschen Post oder so, ne? Firmliche Zustellung, hier liegt wieder irgendwie Post vom Bundeskanzleramt an äh eure Redakteurin Anna.
IFG-Anfrage, oder?
Kanzleramt antwortet, bei IFG-Anfragen irgendwie nur mit so einem Zustellungsschreiben in die,
gehen, äh wenn du nicht da bist und die das nicht das Einschreiben nicht zuschreiben lassen können, um dir eine IFG Ablehnung abzuholen. Das kann ich jede Woche machen. Und ich glaube, das ist so ein bisschen, wollen die uns äh ein bisschen Zeit
Kosten.
Wollen wir uns ein bisschen mal mit den Inhalten auseinandersetzen?
Nein, also eine Sache, denke ich, müssen wir noch an der Stelle äh nochmal behandeln. Jetzt heute geht eigentlich gerade die Meldung die Runde, dass die ganze Nummer ja jetzt abgeblasen wurde. Ähm Range hätte die Ermittlungen jetzt erstmal ruhen lassen. Ähm,
Heiko Maas hat ihn zurückgepfiffen. Wie ist da der Stand? Hat sich wirklich was geändert gegenüber gestern?
Also als wir die FAZ-Meldung, die das ja heute sozusagen als Bündel in die Welt setzte, blasen, dachten wir so, hä, das ist alles seit gestern bekannt. Man muss dazu sagen, bei uns tauchte,
Gestern war mit äh Donnerstag, ne? Donnerstagmittag kam halt die förmliche Zustellung an, aber wir hatten schon ähm,
bekommen, das Süddeutsche oder Rechercheverbund äh ähm dort für Donnerstagabend eine Veröffentlichung geplant hatten, irgendwas mit uns,
dann vielleicht irgendwie na ja vielleicht sind sie mal solidarisch wegen dieser alten Sache mit Deutschlandfunk und sonst vielen. Bringe jetzt mal was. Aber die hatten das vorher schon über ihre Kontakte,
bekommen. Und die hatten auch schon in dem Artikel der Donnerstags abends um achtzehn Uhr dann bei Tagesschauen bei süddeutschen Stand geschrieben, dass die Ermittlungen aufgenommen worden sind, aber erstmal jetzt ein Gutachten,
in Auftrag gegeben wird, um halt rauszufinden, ob das jetzt tatsächlich Staatsgeheimnisse ist, weswegen man jetzt gerade ermittelt,
Die FAZ hat dann Freitagnachmittag quasi mitgesagt, es gibt ein Gutachten, äh wird alles erstmal jetzt auf Eis gelegt. Und es war eigentlich nichts Neues,
gegenüber dem
was wir da halt äh was ein Tag vorher schon stand war. Gleichzeitig ist dann der Mars, kurz danach äh vor äh in Berlin vor die Presse gegangen, hat ein paar Zeilen vorgelesen, wo er sich ein bisschen so distanziert hat, so kam das auch so ein bisschen an. Aber wir fragen uns.
Wie konnte es überhaupt soweit kommen?
Unsere Vermutung war schon von vornherein, wenn der ähm Präsident des äh Verfassungsschutzes Strafanzeige stellt, ist das mindestens gedeckt vom Innenministerium. Das hat sich heute bestätigt
ähm in der Bundespressekonferenz wurde in früheren äh vor Tagen gefragt, ob das Innenministerium davon weiß, da immer nö, wissen wir nix und sonst wie. Heute kam die offizielle Bestätigung
Und ähm der ähm der Maaßen wird sich bei de Maizire in solchen Fragen politisch abgesichert haben
In solchen Fragen sichert man sich nach oben ab, um nicht irgendwie als der Depp dazustehen. Jetzt haben wir Herr Range,
man weiß jetzt nicht, ob er äh also welche Rolle er spielt, weil man könnte halt der Meinung sein, wenn zum ersten Mal oder äh nach seit neunzehn dreiundachtzig Landesverrat gegen äh als Ermittlung wegen Landesverrat gegen Journalisten eingeführt werden, dass man zumindest mal,
dass er bei seinem obersten Dienstherr anfragt, ob er jetzt die Ermittlungen starten soll, weil bei der NSA zeigt sich ja, man muss offensichtlich Ermittlungen nicht starten.
Man kann auch.
Ja ja, oder?
Also äh wir gehen davon aus, dass es da vorher Kontakte, Kommunikation ins Justizministerium gegeben haben muss, weil,
Ähm sonst wäre das ja, also so blöd kann der Range doch eigentlich gar nicht sein. Ist mal die Vermutung. Und ähm also mit anderen Worten, ähm,
Ja, das ist jetzt die Situation, dass ähm äh suggeriert wird, äh es ist alles auf Eis gelegt. Jetzt wo der große Sturm da war,
Wir wissen nicht, wie es weitergeht, weil äh auf Eis gelegt bedeutet nur, der Range wurde dann in FAZ zitiert mit den Worten, das bedeutet, dass wir grad keinen von denen festnehmen werden und gerade keine Hausdurchsuchung machen.
Das ist dieser Begriff Exekutivmaßnahme.
Ja ja, genau, also wo ich echt denke, ey willst du mich verarschen so, ne? Also entweder ähm sofort die ganzen Ermittlungen,
oder wir oder halt immer noch die Bedrohung für uns so, ne? Also entweder weil der kann ja jederzeit sagen, jetzt ist das Gutachten da, brauchen wir keinem zu verraten, jetzt kommen wir mal mit dem und äh dann sind wir halt die Blöden.
Ja und vor allem kann er üblicherweise solche, sind solche Solidaritätswellen ja auch jetzt nicht von ewiger Dauer, vor allem wenn dann irgendwie eine relativ schnell so eine Meldung kommt, wie in der FAZ, wo dann gesagt wird, ja, hier knicken alle ein und so, ne, dann.
Also der Einschüchterungsversuch gegenüber uns bleibt aber der Öffentlichkeit wird damit suggeriert, keine Panik ist jetzt nicht mehr so schlimm.
Aber das ganze Verfahren ist so wie so ziemlich außergewöhnlich. Ähm wir kriegen jetzt einen Brief.
Wo wir informiert werden, dass wir doch Beschuldigte sind und nicht nur Zeugen und gegen unsere anonymen Quellen ermittelt wird. Ähm
und dann überlegt man mit einem Gutachten, ob man jetzt eventuell bei uns eine Hausdurchsuchung macht, was ist denn das für eine Ermittlung? Normalerweise macht man erst die Hausdurchsuchung und dann kriegt man den Brief, das gegen einen ermittelt wird und
dann steht's in der Presse. Ähm das jetzt irgendwie sich auf dieses, das überhaupt der oberste Strafverfolger Deutschlands äh eigentlich
einer der Top-Juristen in Deutschland sich jetzt erstmal in externes juristisches,
holt, ob diese Dokumente überhaupt als Staatsgeheimnis zu bezeichnen sind oder nicht. Das ist eine totale Pussy. Was ist, was ist das überhaupt für eine Veranstaltung? Und jetzt gerade nach dem äh der Justizminister, okay, der
Grade wir äh als Netzpolitik und auch Lokbuchnetzpolitik
Ist ja auch nicht gerade unser Spezialfreund. Man kann ja auch sehen, dass er seine Meinung mal ändert zu bestimmten jetzt politisch relevanten Themen. Aber wenn der heute sich öffentlich hinstellt und sagt, ja ich habe den Ranger mal angerufen und dem gesagt, also ich finde das eigentlich nicht so gut, dass er jetzt Landesverrat gegen äh Journalisten,
ermittelt, kann man sich eigentlich davon ausgehen, dass das jetzt eine politische Entscheidung ist, wie dieses Verfahren weitergehen wird. Also ob die das jetzt
einstellen, was zu hoffen wäre, endgültig einstellen und dann war's das auch.
Gegen uns einstellen oder ob die weiter ermitteln und dann eventuell auch mal eine Hausdurchsuchung machen. Ähm oder uns sogar festnehmen, dass es eine politische Entscheidung, äh die auch nicht nur von Ranger, sondern mindestens von den Ministerien getroffen wird.
Also gerade Range, wir haben ja jetzt, Markus hat's ja schon angesprochen. Ich meine, das ist jemand, der,
ganz offenbar in seiner Tätigkeit politisch gelenkt wird, ne? Also die Ermittlungen zu äh allen NSA ähm Enthüllungen, die ihr da seid eigentlich im Prinzip die ganze Zeit äh.
Gar nicht erst aufnimmt, ja? Die Prüfung eines Anfangsverdachts hat sich ja schon diesen schönen Namen generell Prüfanwalt.
Genau, warum wird bei uns erstmal die Ermittlung gestartet und dann wird erst geprüft, äh ob überhaupt äh,
und bei der kann man gar nicht, weil's gar keinen Anfangsverdacht,
anfangen zu ermitteln. Ich meine, da könnte man auch mal ein Gutachten in Auftrag geben oder eine Medienanalyse oder sonst irgendwas machen oder einfach mal Beamten hinsetzen, der mal googeln soll, was überhaupt jetzt bekannt ist an offiziellen Quellen.
Strafanzeige, die der Chaos Computerclub gestellt hat, hat er, da haben wir jetzt eine Antwort herbekommen vor einiger Zeit, da hatten wir auch bei Lokbotic schon drüber gesprochen und hier bei Netzpolitik org wurde natürlich sowieso drüber berichtet, hatte ja auch,
uns dann darüber in Kenntnis gesetzt, dass er ähm jetzt wegen der wegen des Merkelhandys nicht weiter ermittelt, was niemals ernsthaft irgendwie
Teil unserer Strafanzeige war und äh sagte dann, dass er jetzt auch irgendwie keine weiteren Chance für seine Ermittlungen sieht und AdWords Norden bräuchte man ja nicht zu fragen, denn der würde nicht den Eindruck machen, äh dass er da jetzt irgendwie was zu wüsste.
Also.
Ja, wir wissen auch nichts von Staatsgeheimnissen.
Ja aber ich ich frage mich ähm also diese diese eindeutige politische äh,
Lenkung, die da stattfindet, ne? Ich meine, wir haben einmal irgendwie so eine Edward Snowden äh Sache, die über Jahre
die Medien beschäftigt, die irgendwie Grundrechtsbrüche noch und nöcher irgendwie am Fließband produziert. Inzwischen die Skandale so viele sind, dass man sie nicht mehr zählen kann, dass man gar nicht mehr weiß, über welche man sich am meisten aufregen soll. Und dann kommt hier so eine relativ,
relativ harmlose Veröffentlichung eigentlich noch, ne?
Die aber genau in die gleiche Kerbe schlägt, ja? Und auf einmal seid ihr spielt ihr offenbar in einer Liga mit, äh mit Glen Green World und Edward Snowden, was irgendwie die äh juristischen Keulen angeht, die gegen euch geschwungen werden.
Ja, also das ist ja die große Frage, ne? Also A wie, also wir sehen das erstmal als ganz klaren Einschüchterungsversuch gegen unsere Arbeit.
Aber auch gegen äh wir stellvertretend äh für alle Journalisten, die helfen irgendwie äh Licht ins Dunkle, diese größten Überwachungsskandals in der Geschichte der Menschheit zu bringen.
Alle, die mithelfen, irgendwie mehr Transparenz in diesen Überwachungskomplex zu bringen, woran es kein Interesse von Seiten der Geheimdiensten,
weil deren äh also die Antwort der Bundesregierung ist Vorratsdatenspeicherung, Ausbau des Überwachungsstaates. Das ist die Antwort auf die Snownethüllung. Das wird hier als Machbarkeitsanalyse und nicht als Warnung gesehen. Das ist ja schon ein Skandal. Und gleichzeitig in dem halt
stellvertreten auf uns, also auf uns geschossen wird, stellvertretend auf alle Journalisten, wird natürlich auch äh in Richtung von
Quellen und potenziellen Quellen geschossen und möglicherweise auch schon im Hinblick auf die zukünftige Arbeit im Geheimdienst Untersuchungsausschuss, weil der Verfassungsschutz wird auch noch drankommen
Und der Maaßen, der wird jetzt schon sehen, wie der Schindler unter Beschuss geraten
ist so, ne? Äh durch lauter irgendwie äh äh Leaks in Richtung Journalisten, die halt gezeigt haben, dass wir's hier womöglich,
kalkulierten Verfassungsbruch in Sachen BND und so weiter zu tun haben und ähm man könnte sich vorstellen, dass der Maßen so strategisch vorgeht, dass da jetzt schon mit massiv äh also eigentlich mit der Atombombe irgendwie der größte Waffe, die er zur Verfügung hat, jetzt auf.
Uns stellvertretend für alle anderen schießt, um klarzumachen so. Also wenn ich drankomme, also wenn der Verfassungsschutz dann kommt im Enzo
Dann äh gibt's da ganz andere harte Bandagen. Und wehe, er liegt irgendwas, weil wir schießen auf alles ganz scharf und wir sind hier nicht der BND, der sich das gefallen lässt.
Wenn man sich anschaut, also insbesondere die Signalwirkung,
wellen, ne? Ähm ich meine, dass dass ihr jetzt eingeknastet wird, ist, werdet es, halte ich auch eher noch für unwahrscheinlich. Ähm,
aber wer,
immer äh euch die Dokumente äh zur Verfügung gestellt hat. Kann natürlich schon mit äh mit ernsthaften Konsequenzen rechnen, wenn das eine Person ist, die äh der diese
Geheimnisse auf offiziellen Wege anvertraut wurden. Und ich denke, diese Signalwirkung,
was nützt Chelsea Manning alle Solidarität, ne? Ich meine die die Solidarität hilft dir so lange, wie du noch nicht verurteilt bist, ne? Wenn du einmal dann eingeknastet bist, dann hilft dir das nicht mehr.
Ja zum Glück äh wohnen wir nicht in den USA.
Genau, Deutschland ist ja immerhin Platz zwölf, Herr Rangler ist ja der Pressefreiheit.
Mal sehen, wie das nächstes Jahr ist.
Ja freue ich mich auch schon.
Ja, wir haben ja als CCC heute Morgen noch eine Pressemitteilung rausgegeben, dass wir hoffen, dass Deutschland da jetzt äh von dieser niedrigen, zweistelligen Platzierung endlich einen Vorsprung so in den soliden, dreistelligen Bereich erlangen kann, äh auf dieser
auf dieser äh Liste. Aber ich würde trotzdem ganz gerne bei aller Aufmerksamkeit, die ihr jetzt erfahrt, doch mal unseren Blick auf die ähm Dokumente.
Lenken, denn die Parallele äh,
inhaltlich zu den zu den Snowden-Enthüllungen, ist er hier durchaus äh gegeben. Es geht um die erweiterte Fachunterstützung Internet,
ein Programm des Bundesamtes für Verfassungsschutzes und ich habe mir die die Dokumente natürlich jetzt auch nochmal in angeschaut, hoffe aber natürlich wie immer andere, dass du da der größere Experte zu bist.
Es geht um Massenüberwachung in Internet und Telekommunikation.
Die Dokumente stammen eigentlich sogar schon von zweitausenddreizehn oder eines der äh geheime Haushaltsplan.
Ähm also ich kann natürlich nicht allzu viel sagen, also das, was schon, was schon mal geschrieben hatte und das ist ähm,
Februar zur Massendaten Auswertung von Internet halt Inhalten der basierte unter anderem auf einen Teil des geheimen Haushaltsplan für den Verfassungsschutz aus dem Jahr zwanzig dreizehn,
Das stimmt.
Und dort steht innen drin, wie der Verfassungsschutz dran arbeitet, massenhaft Internetinhalte zu erheben und auszuwerten, darunter auch Kontaktlisten und Beziehungsgeflechte bei Facebook,
ähm da drin stehen dann so Sachen wie der Verfassungsschutz steht vor der Herausforderung aus der Masse an Informationen, die heute einen immer größeren Datenmengen im Internet veröffentlicht werden,
relevanten Informationen zu extrahieren und das mit anderen Daten zu verknüpfen und das ist aufgrund des Umfangs heute manuell nicht mehr möglich. Also,
tatsächlich zockte sich schon vor ähm mittlerweile knapp drei Jahren, als der Haushalt äh gemacht wurde, der Verfassungsschutz. Äh warum das ja immer mehr,
Internet, Inhalte überwacht und dass sie mit der Auswertung manuell nicht hinterher kommen und neue Technik brauchen, neue Leute brauchen.
Und die nennen das selber intern Massendaten, was schon starkes Stück ist der Verfassungsschutz darf im Gegensatz zum Bundesnachrichtendienst, also nicht einfach mal an den DTX gehen und Glasfasern abschnuscheln,
sondern der darf eigentlich immer nur Personen oder Gruppen bezogen äh Daten erheben, mal ganz abgesehen davon, dass er vom BND immer noch Daten
Überwachung äh erhalten kann. Aber hier reden die eben intern selbst von Massentaten und das sind so viele, dass wir überhaupt gar nicht mehr hinterherkommen,
Das war schon äh ein krasses Stück aus dem eigentlich kleineren äh Dokumententeil. Wir waren noch nicht die ersten, die darüber äh berichtet hatten, dass äh Rechercheteam und Neue Deutschland hatten dadrüber auch schon mal berichtet. Aber wir haben dann halt äh das eingeordnet, ähm.
Mit Social Media Überwachung, wie es auch Bundeswehr und BND machen,
und wie immer Statements äh von Politikern dazu eingeholt und dann,
ist der Artikel ja hat so die übliche Szenerunde gemacht von war auf River und dann ist es aber irgendwie wieder eingeschlafen. Ströbele, der ja hier auch zu Gast war,
Ähm der hatte das dann aufgegriffen und eine Frage im Bundestag gestellt, aber das war's dann so ziemlich. Ein öffentlicher Aufmerksamkeit,
auf diesen Bericht bis eben äh wir dann nachgelegt haben im April und dann eben zum Megastreusand äh gestern.
Mich immer noch frage, wie viele Leute denn jetzt eigentlich die original Dokumente gelesen haben, selbst wenn sie jetzt äh irgendwie auf Bild DE gemirt sind, aber wie viele Leute lesen das überhaupt?
Ich finde hier den, den interessanten Satz drin, damit wird das Ziel verfolgt bislang unbekannte und nicht offen erkennbare Zusammenhänge zwischen einschlägigen Personen und Gruppierungen im Internet festzustellen.
Ja? Was haben wir denn in dem anderen äh Dokument äh von April nochmal genauer da drin, haben sie auch gesagt, ähm hm.
Das scheint ja genau dem zu widersprechen, was du gerade sagtest über die Befugnisse des ähm Bundesamt für Verfassungsschutz.
All den Dokumenten, um die wir uns bemühen und die wir auch ähm veröffentlicht haben. Ähm bleiben immer noch viele viele Puzzlestücke, die wir nicht haben,
dass der Verfassungsschutz argumentiert in für sich selbst und damit auch gegenüber ihn nahestehenden Politikern,
ähm dass auch die Daten, die sie von gezielter Überwachung von Einzelpersonen,
auch wenn das durchaus mal hunderte oder tausende sein können. Aber dass selbst die Daten, die sie von diesen hunderten oder tausenden Personen bekommen, zusammengenommen,
total viel Sinn und Massendaten sind und dann über die Daten, die sich aus Hausdurchsuchungen auserwarten,
um Beschlagnahme im Internet und von Devices und klassische Überwachung von Telefonanzapfen,
Schon allein dieser Datenpool, den sie haben, untereinander gerastet werden kann, was sie bisher so nicht gemacht haben. Da war halt irgendwie in Case eins äh Datenträger eins und in K zwei da drüben in der anderen Abteilung,
war das wieder anders und die haben teilweise dann untereinander nicht gewusst, was da ist. Und das wollen die jetzt so
erscheint's mir. Alles in einen Rechner hauen, in eine zentrale Datenbank und dann eben auch Querrastern. Was haben wir eventuell ähm diese Nazis äh mit, keine Ahnung, ähm,
diesen anderen organisierten Kriminalität oder so zu tun oder mit der funktionellen Abfrage von dieser oder jener Aktion.
Interessant, was ich finde, finde Vorstellung auch von den Strukturen haben, ne? Also.
Aber tatsächlich ist das eine Gefahr. Wir wissen nicht ganz genau, was sie damit machen und welche Datenpunkte sie anzapfen. Das hat dann auch Ströbele in der Berichterstattung äh aufgegriffen und das war dann auch äh Kritik. Also hat das als illegal,
und un-ähm zulässig bezeichnet. Äh und in der Tagesschau äh stand, dass die ähm das Verfassungsschutz eigentlich,
keine äh Massendaten abfangen darf ohne Genehmigung der G zehn Kommission. Also genau darum ist eben auch eine politisch,
Auseinandersetzung im Parlament und eventuell auch vor Gerichten im Gange, die aber nur mit ähm Informationen, wenn sie denn auch mal veröffentlicht sind, geführt werden kann, weil solange die Dokumente äh eingestuft sind,
und Abgeordnete und andere Kontrollgremien darüber nicht reden dürfen, äh dann kann das auch eben keine politische Debatte darum geben.
Deswegen ist ja unsere Arbeit so wichtig, äh die nicht nur für die Öffentlichkeit, sondern dann eben auch für die parlamentarische Arbeit,
stattfinden kann, ohne unseren Bericht aus dem Februar hätte Ströbele nie diese Anfragen im Bundestag stellen können oder dürfen. Ich weiß nicht, ob er vorher davon gewusst hat, was zur Phase ist.
Dann haben wir hier diese Anlage Persius. Die gab es aber schon, die gibt's jetzt seit mindestens zehn Jahren, ne?
Das ist dann äh aus dem zweiten Artikel im April, äh dem wir nachgelegt haben, wo wir nochmal,
ähm im Gegensatz zu dieser ungefähr einen Seite aus Teil des Haushalts ähm.
Nochmal ähm die ganze Konzept für eine komplette Einheit beim Verfassungsschutz äh eine Referatsgruppe aus mehreren einzelnen Referaten,
veröffentlicht haben und die Einheiten äh nennt sich äh erweiterte Fachunterstützung im Internet,
das haben wir eben mit dem internen Konzept und der Personalplan veröffentlicht und da war unter anderem eben,
einmal wie sie an Internetdaten kommen, das ist unter anderem mit dieser Telekommunikationsüberwachungsanlage per SEOS nach
griechischen Mythologie. Ähm und die meinen eben, dass die auch Internetkommunikation erfasst bis zu einen äh Gigabit, das war zumindest äh vor zwei Jahren. Das haben sie immer, das erhöhen sie immer äh mehr, weil immer mehr das Traffic anfällt
von Einzelleuten. Und da steht dann eben auch das E-Mail-Chat
protokolle Websessions und Datei von dieser Anlage erfasst werden und weil das so viel äh Bandbreite, so viele Daten sind, wollen sie das eben auch wieder eine Datenbank haben, aufbereiten, visualisieren, miteinander verknüpfen, rastern und so.
Modernisierungen, dreieinhalb Millionen in einem laufenden Haushaltsjahr.
Von dieser einen Ticker Ü-Anlage.
Also irgendwie, wenn wir da von irgendwelchen äh speziell gezielten äh Abhörmaßnahmen im im nur im im Telekommunikations oder im Kommunikationsbereich,
Ist ein Gigabit, aber auch schon ganz ordentliche Bandbreite, oder? Also da kann man ja echt nicht mehr von von gezielt und wenige Personen sprechen, weil die sind ja auch nicht alle gleichzeitig dran, ne.
Ja, ich,
muss aber sagen, ich hätte gern noch ein paar mehr Informationen äh zu dieser Anlage. Also wer auch immer das hört, äh wir nehmen natürlich weiterhin braune Briefumschläge in unserem äh in unserer Sail Mail Postadresse und
verschlüsselte E-Mails oder andere Hinweise entgegen.
Brieftauben notfalls.
Auch Brieftauben äh was gibt's sonst noch so an Kommunikationsmitteln? Also denkt euch einfach was aus. Wahrscheinlich.
Wenn er Feuer macht, ne, mit Rauchzeichen, dann bitte nur vom äh vom Wedding her. Also der BND dahinten ist vom BND Dach.
Fast den BND Neuburg, genau da hinten beim Sonnenuntergang. Die sehen uns wahrscheinlich auch
Äh aber tatsächlich ähm habe ich noch kein vollen Überblick darüber, wie diese Anlage per seus funktioniert, ob die jetzt für jede Einzelperson ein Gigabit hat, das glaube ich nicht oder ob das eben die zentrale,
die Zentrale Kiste ist, wo die ganzen Anschlussüberwachungen aus der sogenannten Telekommunikationsüberwachung,
Also wenn's an Zielen ein Überwachungsziel gibt, einen Verdächtigen, einen potentiellen Terroristen, ein Nazi oder Asylgegner nimmt man das heute ja gibt. Ähm,
Kritik äh oder eben Landesverräter, dann während deren DSL Internet und Telefonanschlüsse ähm ja ausgeleitet vom ähm Telekommunikationsanbieter und dann irgendwie,
in die Verfassungsschutzzentrale in Köln,
und Berlin, das haben wir auch noch entfüllt, kommen wir auch in in Treptow unten, gemeinsam mit Terrorismusabwehrzentrum, geleitet und ich glaube, die per sees Anlage, die steht dann dort um diese,
ähm einzelnen DSL-Anschlüsse zum in eine große Datenbank zu machen und dann eben eine Rasterfahndung äh soziale Netzwerkanalyse äh und so weiter dadrüber zu fahren.
Oder beschweren sie sich ja auch noch, dass irgendwie die Rohdaten, die sind so viel und ein Teil kann per se zwar aufarbeiten, ähm.
Aber manche Sachen, wie zum Beispiel so ein Facebook-Chat, äh da gibt's irgendwie noch kein Plug-in für, da braucht es wie nennen sie das noch spezielle,
im Umgang mit der Anlage und andere Daten kann die Anlage noch nicht äh dekodieren und die braucht müssen da nochmal exportiert werden, um mit anderen äh Werkzeugen bearbeitet,
zum Beispiel ähm dann eben zur Erstellung von Bewegungsprofilen, Beziehungs äh und Beziehungsnetzwerken,
wie wir das schon seit Jahr und Tag auf äh Netzpolitik org predigen, dass das eben mit Vorratsdaten passieren wird.
Um den Bedarf der Abteilungen an Kommunikationsverhalten, Bewegungsprofilen und so zu bedienen,
ähm soll eine zentrale Analyse stellen, genau diese Analysen liefern, äh dieser Auswertungsberichte erstellen,
über die Metadaten, Übersichten der Kommunikationspartner, Kommunikationshäufigkeiten, heimliche und zeitliche und räumliche Verteilung der Kommunikation und eine Schnittstellenanalyse,
ähm wo analysiert herausgefunden werden soll, ob Betroffene verschiedene Überwachungsmaßnahmen in Kontakt
direkten Kontakt miteinander zustehen oder den selben Mittelsmann haben. Also Analyse von Beziehungsnetzwerken. Das ist das, was wir erst seit Jahr und Tag predigen, was mit einer Vorratsdatenspeicherung passieren wird. Und jetzt haben wir das erste Mal schwarz auf weiß, dass äh,
der Verfassungsschutz zwei ganze Einheiten dazu hat und jedem sei nochmal ans Herz gelegt, die Visualisierung der Vorratsdaten von Malte Spitz und Ton Sietz mal zu klicken.
Wo eben ja wunderschön aufbereitet ist wie eben so eine Beziehungsnetzwerke und Bewegungsprofile aussehen nur von Einzelpersonen. Über Gruppen wird das natürlich noch viel aussagekräftiger.
Dann fällt mir auf, hier gibt's noch äh das Referat drei C eins Grundsatz, Strategie und Recht,
also schon noch mal Budget eingeplant wird. Ähm um,
neue Methoden und technische Maßnahmen erfassen, zu erfassen rechtlich zu prüfen, zu testen und weiterzuentwickeln. Wie kriegen die denn, also das heißt, die lassen sich quasi selbst die rechtliche Einschätzung ihrer Maßnahmen,
nochmal im im gesonderten Budget ausweisen, ist sowas normal, dass sie irgendwie sagen, ja okay, wir wir wollen erstmal, wir brauchen wirklich erstmal hier,
ich weiß gar nicht so viele Millionen Beträge und man Jahre in diesem Plan, dass ich gar nicht genau weiß, wo jetzt die Summe hier nochmal steht, dass sie sagen, wir brauchen so und so viele neue Stellen.
Insgesamt fünfundsiebzig für die ganze äh Referatsgruppe, weitere Fachunterstützung, Internet mit sechs äh Einzelreferaten.
Das sind also fünfundsiebzig Mann Jahre pro Jahr.
Eine Stelle ist ja.
Fünfundsiebzig Personen, die teilweise nicht Vollzeit äh sind.
Ähm aber so doch, ich glaube ungefähr fünfundsiebzig Mann Jahre, das ist ja doch Personalbedarf in Höhe von fünfundsiebzig Vollzeit-Äquivalenten. Ich glaube, die haben sogar an die hundert äh Angestellte, die insgesamt fünfundsiebzig äh Vollzeit äh Stunden machen.
Genau, weil da irgendwie, ne, dann sieht man hier immer schön, wie viele Tage sie schätzen.
Und welche äh welche Laufbahn äh die jeweiligen Personen dann haben müssen, also für die für die äh Referatsgruppe drei C eins ist sind dann irgendwie,
hundertsiebenundsiebzig Tage im höheren Dienst vorgesehen. Das heißt, das ist im Prinzip eine.
Dreiviertel Stelle.
Stelle, ne? Den Rest der Zeit kann man sich dann noch anderen Sachen widmen.
Ja oder? Manche Leute über Netzpolitik auch nur eine dreiviertel Stelle. Ähm.
Tatsächlich bin ich jetzt noch kein Experte für die Struktur deutscher Geheimdienste oder das Bundesamt für Verfassungsschutz, aber in einer Referatsgruppe, die sich eben,
explizit zur Bündelung der Internetüberwachung äh gründet und dann eben,
in Referaten, also gerade das Referat sechs zur Informationstechnischen Operativmaßnahmen, IT-Forensischen Analysemethoden, also die tatsächlich auch neue Überwachungsmethoden entwickeln sollen, ist es schon nicht verkehrt,
auch äh eine Restabteilung zu haben, um das zu prüfen, äh was die anderen Kollegen, von denen da so machen sollen und
eben alle rechtlichen Vorgaben eingehalten werden. Wir sind ja hier genau im Spannungsfeld von was es legal illegal scheißegal. Äh was ist Auslegung? Was ist jetzt eine GT-Maßnahme, was muss genehmigt werden, was da,
das Bundesamt für Verfassungsschutz, was wird denen mit dem neuen Verfassungsschutzgesetz, das vor zwei Wochen verabschiedet wurde oder ein paar Wochen schon wieder länger her, wie die Zeit vergeht,
was wir was haben die für neue Befugnisse und wie sieht's mit dem Trojanereinsatz aus, der ja bisher den Verfassungsschutz äh verboten ist und so. Also da auch jemand für Rechtsfragen zu haben, ist tatsächlich nicht so abwegig, gerade wenn sie neue Verfahren entwickeln.
Ist auch scheint auch das am schwächsten äh besetzte Referat zu sein.
Auch nochmal ein Rechtsreferat im im BFV an sich. Die machen halt nur die Rechtssachen, dass tatsächlich nur für das Referat da ist. Das ist schon das ist schon halbwegs nachvollziehbar äh aus deutscher Behördensicht.
Netzwerk Forensik.
Geil, ne? IT-Überwachung. Also ähm nochmal zusammengefasst, also
Der BFV stellt seine seine Abschmuschelaktion mit dieser ähm neuen Zugriffen, Bestandsdaten ab
äh Auskunft, Telekommunikationsüberwachung, diese Anlage per Seeus und so. Das wird neu in einer Einheit gemacht. Ähm dann gibt's äh eben zwei Referate, einmal in Köln und einmal in Berlin die sogenannte inhaltlich technische Auswertung,
von diesen Daten machen und dann gibt's nochmal zwei Referate, sogenannte zentrale Datenanalysestelle auch einmal in Köln, einmal in Berlin, äh die dann eben aus den Daten, die gewonnen und aufbereitet sind.
Eben diese bei äh BND Ausland äh würde man das irgendwie rohdaten Meldungen, Berichte und so nennen,
die dann eben aus diesen Einsen und Nullen, einem Bitch-Strom äh und den aufbereiteten Protokolldaten nochmal fertige Berichte machen. Hier ist das Kommunikationsnetzwerk,
Person oder dieser Gruppe,
und jetzt überlegen wir, wie wir diese Gruppe infiltrieren oder weitere Überwachungsmaßnahmen anordnen oder irgendwann mal hochgehen lassen oder diese Informationen dann mit anderen teilen,
ähm und eine neue, äh die andere über Einheit, die letzte, die äh sechs macht eben,
Informationstechnische operativ Maßnahmen und die entwickeln neue Überwachungsmethoden im,
so konspirativen IT-Überwachungen, unter anderem mit Serverüberwachung und Netzwerktepps. Das war mir auch neu, das fand ich äh ziemlich spannend.
Ähm und die beklagen sich halt einerseits, dass ähm,
durch klassische Kommunikationsüberwachung quasi wenn man den DSL den Internetanschluss einer verdächtigen Person,
abhört, nur ein Teil der Informationen bekommt, weil die haben ja dann eben auch noch ein Smartphone äh Anschluss und dann nutzen sie noch irgendwo Wifi,
und dann sind da auch noch verschlüsselte Daten mit TLS ähm drin und wissen nicht genau, was jetzt hier bei Google sucht und was bei Facebook gemacht wird und äh denken sie sich eben neue Überwachungsmaßnahmen
aus unter anderem die sogenannte Servertelkommunikationsüberwachung, also die
Netzwerkforensing nah am Server. Das geht dann zum Beispiel mit sogenannten,
Netzwerk-Tabs, wo irgendwie Verfassungsschutzagenten in den Rechenzentren gehen und dann so ein kleines Device äh zwischen Switch und äh Server im Reck.
Reinschrauben und dann irgendwie dort noch ein Netzwerkkabel zu einem anderen Server vom Verfassungsschutz geht,
und die dann irgendwie 'ne Server Überwachung machen statt 'ne Überwachung. Was an sich schon mal ein völlig neues Konzept ist, ich mein aus deren Perspektive gibt es ja auch Sinn,
aber rechtlich wirft das immense Fragen auf. Also wenn sie jetzt einen oder zwei Leute oder meinetwegen auch eine Hand voll Leute,
überwachen wollen, die alle denselben Server nutzen. Woher wollen die wissen, wer noch alles diesen Server nutzt? Also wenn ich jetzt an irgendeinen Mailserver denke oder an unseren äh Webserver und Netzpolitik ORG,
gehen eben nicht mehr zu einzelnen Usern, sondern gehen einmal zum Server und nehmen alle Leute, die da sind und,
filtern dann angeblich nur die raus, die sie interessieren, aber das sind die eben bei genau den Fragen. Ist das Massenüberwachung, ist das legitim, Ströbele hat gemeint, äh das ist illegal.
Also das wird, das wird auch heute schon gemacht übrigens, ne, also das.
Wird gemacht? Ja, wir haben dann, ich habe ja die Dokumente nicht nur einfach so äh veröffentlicht, sondern irgendwie noch einen Haufen Recherche drum rum gemacht und so und ich habe dann noch ein paar Slides gefunden,
Landeskriminalamt Hessen, die schon zweitausenddrei äh dreizehn den Workshop
dazu gemacht haben, wo es echt interessante äh Folien dazu gibt äh und eben mal am Nähkästchen geplaudert hat, wie die da so vorgehen mit diesen Server Tabs und auch irgendwie, dass sie mit,
zunächst überfordert sind und spezielle Tools brauchen und so.
Also hier steht auf der Slide, die du da auch da zugefügt hast. Oft können Betreiber die Daten selbst ausleiten, dann braucht man kein Tab.
Ähm das wird auch gerne übrigens genutzt, um ähm Tor äh an äh Gegentor hin Services vorzugehen und Tornutzer irgendwie zu erkennen, dass man halt verschiedene TKÜs an entsprechenden Stellen ansetzt.
Na du möchtest äh wenn du jetzt zum Beispiel einen hidden Service äh finden möchtest, dann interessiert dich ja ähm,
kannst du ja das einzige, was du was du machen kannst, um dir zu markieren, ist zum Beispiel viel oder wenig Traffic auf den lassen, ne?
Was sicher zum Beispiel interessiert ist, ob der HIN-Service verschwindet, wenn du mal kurz das Kabel rausziehst, ja? Das heißt, sie müssen.
Musste aber da schon mal eine Idee haben, in welchem RZ, in welchem Reck wir in der Kiste stehen können.
Wenn du dir jetzt geschickt vorgehst und viele dieser Tabs positionierst, dann kannst du irgendwann nach und nach immer mehr eingrenzen, in welchem Bereich sich der befindet,
dann gehen sie teilweise sehr schnell hin und packen diese Dinger dazwischen und nutzen genau diese Tabs, die dann eben trotzdem nur Blindenverkehr sehen äh oder also verschlüsselten Verkehr sehen, um einfach Traffic aufkommen zu sehen und so weiter, um,
dadurch dann ähm immer weiter einzugrenzen.
Das habe ich noch nicht gehört. Tatsächlich gibt's ja bei Tor auch gerade die die Hidden Service des Attacken, an denen gerade gearbeitet wird, das zu fixen und wenn du die NSA als Level hast, die haben ja sowieso ganz andere Möglichkeiten, globale passive Netzwerkanalyse zu machen und so.
Machen deutsche Behörden mit diesen Tab.
Gras, sehr interessant sehr interessant.
Und da eben natürlich auch, wie du gerade nennst, das Risiko, wenn ich an mich an einen Server dranklemme, äh ist eben das Problem, dass ich das nicht vorhersehbar ist, welche Nutzer sich alle noch mit diesem Server,
verbinden werden. Und das heißt, dass ich die alle mit in meine in mein Fischnetz nehme,
und äh sie dann eben zum Beifang werden in meiner in meiner Maßnahme.
Ja, der Ströbele hat uns zu dem Artikel zu der genau der Maßnahme eben auch gesagt,
also Massenüberwachung solcher Art direkt an Datenservern scheinen ihnen gesetzlich nicht genehmigungsfähig zu sein. Also der bezeichnet das ganz klar als illegal.
Aber das kann er eben auch erst öffentlich tun, wenn er davon weist und wenn das auch öffentlich steht, sonst darf er dadrüber nicht reden. Selbst ich weiß ja nicht, ob der das vorher wusste oder nicht.
Ah ja er wird es auch nicht sagen dürfen, ob er es vorher wusste oder nicht, ne? Der darf ja immer nur.
Immer im NSA Untersuchungsausschuss, da sagt er ja auch immer,
Was war irgendwie letztens puffaler und so da als und geredet haben die sitzt ja auch im parlamentarischen Kontrollgremium, aber da drüber darf ja nie jemand reden, äh ein Wort, was dort verloren wurde,
und dann hat äh Strömle ähm na, Pofalla gefragt,
ob er dies oder das äh so ungefähr im Kontrollgremium gesagt hatte und er hat Profiler gemeint, ja, wissen sie doch, sie waren doch da und strömen das so, ja, aber ich darf ja nicht darüber reden, nur wenn sie sagen, was sie dort gesagt haben, dann darf ich darüber auch öffentlich Bezug nehmen.
So
Damit war die, war das Gespräch zu Ende oder.
Ach, das war dann wieder so ein äh Abfall von äh ich wenn sie nicht mich weiter so nerven, dann laber ich hier einfach bisschen Zeit vorbei, ist ungefähr.
Haben wir äh noch Teile dieser neuen Referate hier vergessen. Wir wollen ja sicherstellen, dass da möglichst ausführlich nochmal äh die Öffentlichkeit drüber in Kenntnis gesetzt wird. Wenn wir jetzt schon diesen.
Ich fand einen Teil dieser äh sechser Einheit äh die neue äh Überwachungsmethoden entwickeln soll, noch cool ähm irgendwie hier beschreiben sie selber von Informationstechnischen, operativ Maßnahmen zu verdeck
Informationserhebung nicht öffentlich gegen äh zugängliche Informationen im Internet.
Kannst du nochmal wiederholen.
Informations IT Operativmaßnahmen zu verdeckten Informationserhebung von nichtöffentlich zugänglichen Informationen.
Wollen Informationen haben, die nicht öffentlich zugänglich sind und die verdeckt erheben,
insbesondere zählen dazu konspirative IT-Überwachung von Online-Diensten, zum Beispiel Server TKÜ, also TKÜs, Telekommunikationsüberwachung, Server TKÜ, Forenüberwachung, E-Mail TKÜ,
Also ich habe ja
Nachdem ich mich damit beschäftigt habe, äh so ungefähr ein Bild, was dieses Serverticker Ü sein könnte, eben diese Netzwerk-Tabs direkt an selber, was eine E-Mail TKÜ ist,
ähm keine Ahnung, ob das dasselbe so eine Server TKÜ an einem Mailserver ist, äh weiß ich nicht, aber von einem Server kann ja nicht nur Mail sein, äh das kann ja alles Mögliche drauf sein.
Ähm fand, fand ich spannend, wo war hier die andere äh Maßnahme? Genau.
Durchführung von Operativmaßnahmen zu verdeckten Informationserhebungen über Computernetze. Das klingt für mich echt sehr nach Onlinedurchsuchung oder Quellen-TKÖ, äh aber das taucht dort nicht auf, äh weil den Staatsbürger darf der Verfassungsschutz eben nicht einsetzen, laut BKA-Gesetz,
oder zumindest nach dem äh Urteil des Bundesverfassungsgericht von zwotausendacht. Also da habe ich, da habe ich mich kurz gefragt, meinen die jetzt einen Staatstrojaner?
Plant der Verfassungsschutz jetzt für den Staatstrojaner, aber dann habe ich irgendwie mit einer Handvoll äh hochrangiger Jura-Experten zum Geheimdienst und Überwachungsbereich geredet und die haben ja alle gemeint, also
das klingt vielleicht ein bisschen ähnlich, aber das kann das einfach nicht sein, weil der Verfassungsschutz darf kein Trojaner einsetzen und wenn sie das wirklich tun würde, dann wären sie selten dämlich, weil das ist äh ziemlich,
ziemlich offensichtlich verboten. Also gehe ich auch derzeit davon aus, dass sie das nicht tun, sonst hätten wir noch einen ganz anderen Skandal im Land.
Verdeckte einfach.
Aber wer Informationen dazu hat, immer her damit.
Ich finde das sehr schön deinen äh Artikel, das ist der Aprilartikel, ne, wo viele Fragen bleiben, schön äh wo wir äh äh wo du die Antworten entgegen nimmst.
Na ja, also,
wie bei jedem Artikel. Ähm das ist halt einfach guter journalistischer Stil, ähm als wir den Artikel veröffentlicht haben, haben wir natürlich vorher den Verfassungsschutz auch gefragt, so von wegen
hier, das und das ist Phase, dazu haben wir hier fünf Fragen oder zehn, ich weiß nicht mehr wie viel es war, ist fast ein halbes Jahr her
Äh was ist ihre Meinung dazu, was ihre Kommentare dazu, was ihre Einschätzung und so? Und ich hatte irgendwie einmal zwei Wochen ich den Artikel veröffentlicht habe, habe ich eine Mail geschickt, dann habe ich eine Woche vorher nochmal eine E-Mail geschickt
äh und da kam nie eine Antwort. Normalerweise kommt da irgendwie so wie ein dass es eingestuft, darüber können wir nicht reden, aber seien Sie versichert, dass alles nach Recht und Gesetz,
und ich habe aber da gar nichts von dem bekommen. Nicht mal den geh weg, mit dir reden wir nicht. Null. Nada. Äh,
Normalerweise haben sie ja immerhin so eine Standardantworten. Ähm,
fand ich ganz äh herausragend, denn das ist mir bisher noch nicht so oft passiert, weil mir passiert's eher äh andersrum, dass äh,
einfach immer dasselbe sagen, äh nämlich nichts und dass ich dann irgendwann für selber aufgebe nachzufragen, aber dass sie irgendwie äh also mit nichts meine ich, darüber können wir nicht reden oder wollen wir nicht reden,
dass sie gar nicht mehr antworten, äh fand ich schon krass. Jetzt weiß ich auch, warum. Äh der will einfach nicht, dass ich über geheime Dokumente an sich geredet.
Grade der Maaßen ist ja aber eigentlich doch sehr kommunikativ, ne? Also der äh ich habe ja auch schon mal, war auch schon mal dort eingeladen bei einer Veranstaltung, einer öffentlichen.
Schon mit den Maaßen geredet?
Nee, ich war nicht, äh ich habe nicht persönlich mit ihm gesprochen, aber ich habe dann ich habe noch einen Brief von ihm bekommen. Danke schreiben, dass ich da war.
Hast einen Dankesbrief von Maaßen bekommen? Wollen wir den neben den neben den GBA-Brief da oben hängen?
Liegt noch der liegt noch irgendwo im CCC rum, ja. Der war's dann auch sehr blöd war, weil er so, ey, du hast hier Post vom Verfassungsschutz.
Ja, das haben wir auch.
Ja, aber bei mir war's nur freundlicher Dank. Ne, und ähm also der sucht ja schon den Austausch, eigentlich.
Ja, der hat ja auch mal eine Transparenz-Offensive angekündigt. Ähm.
Ich dachte erst, das wäre die jetzt, was.
Näher ja, das äh müssen wir halt machen, äh genau wie Schindler, der hat ja auch eine Transparenzoffensive angekündigt. Ähm.
Bestand dann daraus, äh die äh BND äh Außenstellen, die schon auf Wikipedia stehen, äh dann auch mal ein ordentliches Schild äh zu geben, dass sie.
Nicht alle, genau.
Ionosphäreninstitut.
Ob es gibt eine.
Und es ich glaube, es gibt eine äh lichtdurchflutete ähm Zuschauer oder Besucher ähm Empfangshalle jetzt bei dem neuen BND-Gebäude, wo man eine Informationszentrum eingerichtet hat, wo man so Broschüren holen kann.
Ja, das ist die Transparenzoffensive. Das Licht scheint jetzt in den BND-Neubau. Ähm wenn sie schon keine Wasserhähne haben, aber das sind anders Themen.
Nee, äh tatsächlich äh hätte ich mich ja gefreut über eine Transparenzinitiativ äh Offensive. Äh wie gesagt, mehr als Fragen stellen.
Wiederholt, darum bitten, dass ich wirklich das ernst meine und gerne auch eine Antwort hätte. Kann ich nicht tun. Mich hat der Maaßen noch nicht eingeladen und ich bezweifle auch, dass er das in naher Zukunft tun wird.
Ich bezweifle auch, dass du eine einer Einladung folgen würdest nach und das würde ich wahrscheinlich jetzt auch nicht mehr tun,
Beides war, ich hatte da die Gelegenheit äh zum Austausch mit dem ähm wie heißt der nochmal? Burkhard Evens glaube ich,
auf so einer öffentlichen Podiumsdiskussion. Das war der, war oder ist der Leiter für äh Spionageabwehr? Das war dann sehr witzig mit ihm über den NSA-Skandal zu sprechen, weil er natürlich fester Überzeugung war, dass die die Amerikaner aus welchem Grund
denn die Amerikaner uns auszuspielen.
Sind doch die guten.
Es war äh das war ein einfacher,
einfacher Gegner auf dem Podium. Ähm und es ist irgendwie zwei, drei Jahre ein, zwei Jahre her, glaube ich, anderthalb Jahre.
Wie geht's jetzt weiter? Ähm ihr habt euch rechtlichen Rat.
Nein.
Oh man ey.
Was ist das von der TAZ selber?
Morgen entscheiden, das Titelbild.
Von Markus und Andre mit Gaffer übermund. Journalisten des Jahres.
Immerhin habe ich das achtzehn C drei Shirt eine auf diesen blöden Foto.
Und ich habe mich wenigstens rasiert gehabt.
Lassen wir das Thema. Ja wie es weiter geht und wir trinken erstmal unser Bier aus und machen den Podcast fertig, aber wir trinken nicht so viel Bier wie gestern.
Darf man schon erzählen, dass hier gestern angestoßen wurde, ne?
Ja, das war ganz schön anstrengend. Als ich heute Morgen hier ins Büro kam, die ersten.
Ja, aber auch weil wir so viel Arbeit hatten. Wir waren bis nach Mitternacht im Office in der Presseanfragen beantwortet und Sachen gemanagt. Irgendwann wirst du gaga, kannst du ja nicht irgendwie äh vierzehn Stunden im Büro sitzen und dann nicht auch irgendwann mal ein Bier aufmachen nach Sonnenuntergang.
War um neun Uhr heute Morgen hier mit dem ersten Kamerateam anstatt raus auf mich wartete, da musste ich erstmal hier die ganzen Bierflaschen wegräumen, weil die gestern aber.
Oder die praktisch später noch.
Besonders schön fand ich eigentlich gerade die Situation als Telefon klingelte. Wer ist dran gegangen? Ich ähm ähm.
Daniel oder Erik?
Daniel, glaube ich, Daniel ist dran gegangen. Sagte, nee, Bäckedal ist gerade, äh nee, Ana war das, Anna ist dran gesagt, nee ist gerade nicht hier. Wie ist schlecht? Ja klar, klar, ist schlecht, verstehe ich. Ach so, Live-Interview im Radio.
Und dann mussten sie dich erstmal aus dem Fernsehinterview im Flur zum Live-Interview im Radio holen.
Ist mir heute auch paar Mal passiert. Da sind Live-Interview geskatut war und dass dann nicht eingehalten werden konnte. Das Telefone haben nicht mehr stillgestanden. Heute war so ziemlich jedes Kamerateam Deutschlands äh.
Nee, nee, nee, also es gibt so einen Unterschied, ne, also wenn Facebook neue Features rausbringt, ist als erstes irgendwie RTL zwei hier. Äh die haben sich nicht gemeldet, aber alle, die über Politik berichten, waren.
Aber sonst, also ich habe ja einige schon erlebt, äh aber ich habe sowas wie heute äh habe ich noch nicht erlebt. Also.
Gestern waren die alle am Telefon äh und heute kamen die dann alle mit den Kameras und Interviews.
Nee, nee, aber auch, also der Typ bisher erst um elf hier angekommen, ne? Mein Telefon klingelte ab äh sieben irgendwie durchgängig so, ne? Es war gerade aufgelegt, nächste dran oder die ganze Zeit. Ich habe noch gar nicht den Abi abgehört. Ich glaube, den lösche ich gleich komplett.
Ja, dann die äh die Tagesschauseite gerade war ja wirklich der Hammer. Also irgendwie der,
die Tagesschau beginnt. Drei Minuten oder so für euer Thema empfiehlt dann noch auf Tagesschau DE finden sie viele Hintergründe. Drei fette Artikel, alles obendrauf. Also ich meine.
Gestern Abend auch auf wir waren irgendwie Aufmacher in fast allen Medien, zumindest die, die über Politik auch mal berichten. Also deswegen, das hat uns sehr gefreut, diese ähm Solidarisierung.
Und jetzt oben die Liste an Videos äh bei der Tagesschau hundert Sekunden zwanzig Uhr aktuelle Videos, auch alles Netzpolitik Logo und dann unten alles Gute im Ruhestand, Herr Kommentar.
Noch einer Landesverrat auf Tagesschau DE.
Ja, das das Lustige ist in ihrem Blog schreibt gerade die Redaktion der Tagesschau oder zumindest habe ich gerade gesehen
äh dass sie äh den Rat ihrer ähm Justizabteilung bekommen haben, unsere Dokumente nicht zu hosten, sondern sie verlinken sie nur.
Der wird nur aus Deutschland bis hin zu Bild-Zeitung alle irgendwie mit ihrer Rechtsabteilung geklärt haben, dass sie die auch spiegeln können. Aber unsere öffentlich-rechtlichen.
Aber dann wäre der, dann wäre der Link ja äh ehrlich gewesen, kein Landesverrat auf Tagesschau DE. Habt ihr mal geguckt, ob der Server noch steht? Weil ich.
Auf Land, das war auch der Server. Techniker ist informiert, dafür können wir nichts. Wir sind hier nur die Typen, die das WordPress klicken. Äh ich habe zwar zufällig ruht, aber ich bin da nicht ersichert und ich.
Also die größte Erfahrung aus dieser Geschichte war beim nächsten Mal informieren wir zuerst den Admin und dann drücken drücken wir auf.
Ja, aber der war halt im Urlaub.
Dann drücken dann drücken wir auf.
Ja, aber die äh GBR hat uns ja die Brief geschickt. Äh wir haben ja im Februar und im April auf Veröffentlichung geklickt. Da war er da.
Genau, da hätte der Advent irgendwie den Server besser gerettet.
Ähm war das jetzt eigentlich auf irgendeine Anfrage noch? Hattest du, hattest du dich bei denen erkundigt oder kam die Sabri.
Nee, nee, der kam und zwar laut ähm ähm einem unserer Anwälte. Ähm.
Gibt es eine Verjährungsfrist von sechs Monaten bei ähm Pressesachen. Ähm,
Also wahrscheinlich und äh im Februar ist ja die erste Sache gewesen und wenn eine benachrichtigt wird, dann wird diese Verjährungsfrist ausgesetzt. Das heißt, äh,
wahrscheinlich weil die dachten so, also es könnte auch sein, dass sie dachten, so Sommerpause, jetzt also im nächsten Monat ermittelt keiner und dann ist wieder sechs Monate nach Februar ähm rum
und sie müssen halt jetzt mal ganz schnell irgendwie uns mitteilen, damit irgendwie in die Sommerpause gehen können und nicht erst mal gegen uns heimlich weiter ermitteln können.
War aber ein bisschen komisch, denn sie beziehen sich da auf
die Verfallsfristen vom Berliner Journalistengesetz, Berliner Pressegesetz, was schon mal gut ist, dass wir uns als Presse anerkennen, gebe ja irgendwie noch den Hebel uns, na klar sind wir Presse, wir haben Presseausweisung, wir machen schon lästige Arbeit, also sind wir Journalisten,
gebe ja noch den Ansatzpunkt uns äh zu irgendwie diffamieren,
Internetblogger oder so. Jedenfalls steht im Berliner Pressegesetz äh das Vergehen nach sechs Monaten verjähren, aber Verbrechen erst nach einem Jahr äh verjähren. Und äh Landesverrat, das hat ist ein Verbrechen und nicht nur ein Vergehen.
Ordnungswidrigkeit.
In Ordnung für.
Sonst wäre ja auch der Generalbundesanwalt gar nicht zuständig.
Ne?
Da oder was? Ja, wahrscheinlich.
Nee, wegen den Dokumenten. Wahrscheinlich. Ja, dass der Maßen da noch nicht auf den Gedanken gekommen ist.
Der Scheu sich ja bisher öffentlich äh Stellung zu nehmen, weil ähm also zumindest bis vorgestern äh hätte er mit jeder Antwort ja bestätigt, dass unsere Dokumente echt sind äh übrigens danke ist glaube das bestreitet niemand mehr.
Aber krass, dass die selbst die Tagesschau sich nicht traut, das macht mir jetzt ein bisschen Sorgen.
Warum? Erzähl.
Gibt da so eine kleine.
Irgendein Bernd im Internet.
Don't Chris at home.
Spiegel online schrieb irgendjemand äh hat sogar eine Seite gemacht, keiner weiß, wer das ist.
Wir sollten tatsächlich nochmal auf unsere Freunde von Korrektiv verweisen, die hier äh gestern unter den vielen Leuten waren, die dann einfach im Büro aufgeschlagen sind, Bier mitgebracht haben und gesagt haben, ey du, danke, was können wir tun
äh und die kamen auf die Idee und haben heute Morgen selber die Dokumente nochmal veröffentlicht, weil ist ja Presserecht,
Freiheit ist in Angriff nicht nur auf uns, sondern äh allen möglichen Journalisten und,
und Korrektiv hat dann tatsächlich die Dokumente, um die es geht, die angeblich das Land verraten sollen, äh selbst auf ihrer Webseite ähm,
dann Strafanzeige gegen sich selbst gestellt äh beim Generell Bundesanwalt, um eben äh öffentlich zu beweisen, wie lächerlich äh diese Anschuldigungen sind und dass man das mit Fresse ja wohl nicht macht.
Das ist aber ein Sport, den würde ich jetzt grundsätzlich nur äh Redaktion und Presseerzeugnissen.
Am besten welchen mit Rechtsabteilung oder guten Erfahrungen rechts Dingen.
Ja, falls ihr uns eine Rechtsabteilung spenden wollt, nur zu.
Genau, Spenden müssen wir natürlich drauf hinweisen. Vielleicht sowieso mal so zum Hintergrund auch noch. Ich meine, Netzpolitik Org seid, äh wann hat ihr vor zweitausendvier, also jetzt seit elfeinhalb Jahren.
Vierten September feiern wir elf Jahre Netzpolitik mit einer eigenen Konferenz und Party. Kommt vorbei.
Genau, erstmal Konferenz, dann Party. Wichtig.
Andersrum her, schlimm. Das ist dann wie heute.
Wird nicht müde, das mit der Party zu betonen. Ähm im Prinzip immer so ein bisschen aus deiner sonstigen Tätigkeit querfinanziert gewesen. Seit einiger Zeit jetzt.
Der hat einfach nie gearbeitet in seiner Firma, sondern immer nur Facebook geklickt nebenbei.
Das hast, das hast du jetzt über deinen Chef gesagt.
Wir nennen ihn Chef.
Ähm aber war immer äh ich meine, ihr standet jetzt hier nie wirklich dick im Saft, was das finanzielle angeht, ne. Also die die Redaktion konnte immer operieren, aber ähm.
Es ist jetzt auch nicht eine äh so so üppig ausgestattete Redaktion, wie man sich das vielleicht vorstellen würde bei anderen Onlineseiten, oder?
Nö, schön wär's, ne. Also, andererseits äh ich habe mich heute auch mit Journalisten unterhalten, die eher darüber klagten, dass äh sie in äh
Redaktionsumgebung arbeiten, wo immer mehr gespart wird und alle Angst um ihren Job haben. Die verdienen zwar im Moment mehr Geld und äh sind aber nicht unbedingt irgendwie mit einer,
ausgestattet und äh sind da ein bisschen neidisch auf uns, dass wir halt wenig Geld verdienen, aber äh wo
viele das Gefühl haben, dass wir davon auch noch die nächsten Jahre leben können. Aber ja, also wir sagen immer, ähm das, was wir hier verdienen, das hat er Tanzniveau,
ähm und bei anderen Medien kriegt man wahrscheinlich äh locker das Doppelte, aber dafür haben wir hier die Freiheit äh wenig Meetings. Äh äh.
Musik, die im Hintergrund läuft, wenn ich gerade Live-Interviews sind.
Genau und äh ja, was haben wir noch für Vorteile, blinkende Lichter.
Näher unten. Ja, tatsächlich. Also ich habe mich auch vor Kurzem mit anderen Johnnys unterhalten und die haben dann gemeint,
nicht dein Ernst, die Summe, die du mir grade gesagt hast, die du verdienst, oder? Das ist ja lächerlich gering. Äh aber wir machen das ja auch nicht irgendwie, weil wir das als äh und weil wir irgendwie
unser Einkommen erwirtschaften wollen und deswegen diesen Job gefunden haben, sondern wir haben das erst gemacht und haben ähm diese inhaltliche Arbeit, weil das eben genau unser Ding ist äh und haben das dann zu unserem Job umtransformiert. Ähm tatsächlich ist das so eher Aktivismus
der auch die Miete äh und den Kühlschrankinhalt bezahlt, äh statt irgendwie der ja die ähm,
Karriereleiter, Schritt äh mit denen man dann das Eigenheim finanziert. Also reich werden wir hier nicht.
Aber andererseits ähm ja, also wir freuen uns immer über finanzielle Unterstützung. Auch diejenigen, die regelmäßig reinkommen durch einen Dauerauftrag
weil das ermöglicht uns auch zu wachsen. Also man sieht das wahrscheinlich auch in der Geschichte der letzten zwei, drei Jahre, als wir vor zwei Jahren
belangen sie erst her auf Leserfinanzierung umgesetzt haben, da waren Andre und ich hier und wir haben defizitär gearbeitet. Ähm seitdem war es uns möglich, A uns irgendwie zu refinanzieren plus halt mittlerweile mit Konstanze, Thomas und Anna.
Drei weitere Personen,
zwar auf eins Komma sieben Stellen, so zwei Halbtagsschälen, eine Dreiviertelställe einzustellen. Aber man sieht auch, glaube ich, dass uns das sehr geholfen hat,
dass wir ähm in den letzten zwei Jahren großen Professionalisierungsschub gemacht haben, dass wir einfach viel mehr Zeit haben, uns auch äh,
bestimmte Sachen zu konzentrieren, während vorher alles explodierte und man sagte zu eins oder alleine oder zu zweit und äh kam dem dann nicht hinterher. Insofern hilft uns
alles an Wachstum, noch mehr abzudecken, weil also ich erkläre das immer so daran, den Gag als ich anfing, wenn Netzpolitik Punkt org, da haben wir uns echt gefreut, wenn einmal im Monat der Bundestag irgendwas zur Netzpolitik gemacht hat
Und heute macht der Bundestag alle zwei Wochen Sitzungswoche und in äh zwanzig von dreiundzwanzig Ausschüssen geht's um Netzpolitik und zwar nicht nur einmal, sondern mehrfach. Und wir kriegen das alles gar nicht mehr gecovert, aber eigentlich ist unser Ziel.
Überall das äh quasi äh Frühwarnsystem für digitale Bürgerrechte zu sein und alles zu covern und
überall sagen zu können, okay, hier ist grad irgendwas am schief laufen. Hier müssen wir äh viel mehr drauf achten. Und gleichzeitig ist man auf tausend Baustellen. Ich meine, grad äh
wurde ich im Interview gefragt, der wollte jetzt nicht eine Kampagne für Whistleblogger machen, so. Woher meinten der, ja super, äh
Wir haben halt gerade hier noch Netzzentralite in der EU, Störerhaftungsverstimmung, die Vorratsdatenspeicherung kommt. Wir haben den ganzen Snowdenkomplex noch nicht aufgearbeitet. Ähm
und und und äh und die Urheberrechtsreform steht vor der Tür. Äh natürlich hätten wir jetzt Lust drauf, aber wir sind hier fünf Personen verteilt auf drei Komma sieben, fünf Stellen und irgendwer ist immer krank oder hat
auch mal Urlaub, weil das ist ja so, ähm ist ja auch wichtig. Äh auf jeden Fall ähm ist das hier nicht vergleichbar mit anderen Redaktionen.
Ich habe auf Sprung gelesen, mein Urlaub ist abgesagt, äh aber tatsächlich möchte ich auch nochmal äh das betonen und mich bedanken. Das ist eine ziemlich luxuriöse Position, in der wir sind, eben vollkommen unabhängig äh von Anzeigen,
und vor allem von also von anderen Netzweltredaktionen, hören wir teilweise, ja, die müssen halt äh Apple machen für die Klick
Zahlen ab und zu mal was mit Poren und früher waren's die Piraten. Und wir sind halt vollkommen unabhängig von so einem inhaltlichen Sachen, weil wir halt irgendwie nicht nach,
oder nach User-Tracking oder so ein Zeug Werbung verkaufen, bei uns schaltet überhaupt so gut wie äh niemand Werbung. Und das ist auch ganz in Ordnung, das ist echt eine luxuriöse Position,
alle unsere Inhalte komplett vollständig äh kostenlos ins Internet zu stellen, weitestgehend ohne Tracking bis auf VG-Wort,
unter einer freien Lizenz
und dafür aber eine freiwillige Refinanzierung von unseren Leserinnen und Lesern zu bekommen durch Spenden, also wir zwingen niemand zu spenden. Das wird auch immer frei und offen bleiben. Wir es gibt einen Full Feed, aber eben genau diese.
Direkte Bindung zu unseren Leserinnen und Lesern, äh die super, die ist top, die hält uns eben den Rücken frei, die ermöglichst äh
es uns zu arbeiten, ohne uns mit so einer Werbeabteilung und so, naja, wirklich andere Relationen haben genau so einen offiziellen Oberhelden, Mist und so,
ohne uns damit rum äh schlagen zu müssen. Und ich finde das super, dass wir irgendwie aus diesem jahrelangen Einmann-Zeit-Job-Projekt von Markus jetzt irgendwie bei fünf Personen sind,
und tatsächlich ich mich auch so ein bisschen aus dem Day to day Ding rausziehe und halt irgendwie mal eine Woche abtauche, nur ein Dokumentenwühle,
und dann aber eine Story macht, für die man Landesverrat bekommt,
aber währenddessen dreht sich die Welt halt weiter, wie Marco schon gesagt hat, erstens wir werden nicht reich und zweitens auch wenn wir jetzt schon fünf Leute sind, wir schaffen's trotzdem noch nicht annähernd das abzudecken, was bei uns den ganzen Tag so aufschlägt in unseren Themenfeld,
wir haben jetzt nicht vor, morgen gleich zwanzig Leute zu sein, aber wir sind extrem dankbar für jede einzelne Spende die ganze Zeit,
seitdem wir damit angefangen haben und jetzt aber gerade auch in den letzten Tagen, als es heute zehn Leute in das Office gelaufen und haben uns hier in die Spendendose mal einen Geldschein reingesteckt,
cool ist.
Ja
Das mit der Werbung wurde ja schon auch mal versucht, ne? So ist das ja nicht. Hat aber auch keiner hier geworben.
Nee, aber das war, das war ja das Grundproblem. Es gab ja eine Zeit lang irgendwie in Blocks so die Hoffnung irgendwie auch ähm mit eigenen Blog vermarkten in die Richtung, so ja, aber,
eigentlich eigentlich eine äh sinnvolle Idee, sich sagen wir mal nicht von großen, riesigen Konzernen abhängig zu machen, sondern das selbst zu organisieren, ne. Ich meine, wie damals irgendwie dreißig vor dreißig Jahren in einer Punke-Phase irgendwie, man bildet gegründet halt Labels äh und Vertriebsstrukturen. Aber es hat halt überhaupt
nicht geklappt und eigentlich so die einzigen so Blogs oder Online-Medien, die sich finanzieren können über Werbung, das ist halt Gadgets,
auch vor allen Dingen über Affiliate und Sponsoring diese ganze Mode und Unterhaltungszeug irgendwie ganzen aber wir machen ja A,
Politik,
und auch in der Zeitung wird normalerweise Anzeigen nicht in Politik äh verkauft, sondern ich habe äh sagen wir mal alles andere finanziert den Politikteil mit den man halt fürs Renommee und ähm eine Reputation braucht. Äh und das hat er halt für uns halt,
Zeigt selbst, wenn wir mal Werbung verkauft haben, hat ja auch keiner gesehen, ne. Na, ich meine, ja, ja, weil ja, ja, wir, ja, ja, ja, ich bin auch immer,
irritiert, wenn ich auf andere Seiten ohne AdBlocker gehe, weil ich weiß gar nicht, wo der Inhalt ist, aber das war das Ding so, als selbst wenn wir Anzeigen,
haben, dann wurden sie halt nicht ausgeliefert, ne, weil neunzig Prozent unserer Leser zu Recht äh Anti-Tracking Tools einsetzen und wir sie auch immer dahin schulen, dass man halt sich selbst schützen muss, weil man liest ja immer so viel Böses im Internet.
Ich weiß noch, als ich hier vor Jahren das das alte Netzpolitik gebaut habe und dann diese Werbedinger einbauen sollte, ich auch da immer gesessen habe, hm, komm nicht, funktioniert nicht, bis ich dann irgendwann gemerkt habe, okay, muss man den Wärmeblockhaus mache.
Internet.
Du neunzig oder so.
War echt geil. Also da gab's doch, gab's ja nicht auch irgendwann mal so eine komische Werbung. Da war das war als ich noch hier saß, da gab's irgendeine beknackte Werbung auf Netzpolitik org.
Wo das wir alle nicht gemerkt haben, weil wir.
Mit Werbeblock gehabt, die ganze Zeit gesehen haben und dann da war halt irgend so ein riesiges Banner von irgend 'n Scheiß drauf und dann mussten wir da noch anrufen, ja.
Genau, unsere Leser melden uns so.
Was habt ihr denn für eine beklagte Werbung? Wie, wir haben Werbung auf der.
Aber das wird deutlich, dass wir eben unser Finanzierungsmodell nicht von Werbung und äh Filme, die uns wohlgesonnen äh aufgebaut haben, sondern eben auf freiwillige Leserfinanzierung. Finde ich toll oder vielen Dank, liebe Leute.
Das ist äh euer einziger Ruf nach Unterstützung jetzt. Ihr wollt äh nein, nein, ich meine.
Wie viel willst du denn noch haben? Also demnächst führen wir demnächst mal eventuell Fördermitgliedschaften ein. Damit man.
Ihr habt ja, nein, ich meine, ihr habt ja unglaublich viele äh äh Angebote bekommen, ne?
Aber die Leute bieten uns einen Barniser an, aber Techniker ist informiert und das ist alles tricky.
Genau, also da seid, also das ist, sagen wir mal, ein Hauptproblem, was ich so in äh fünfzehn Jahren Aktivismus immer gemerkt habe, du kriegst eine ganze Menge Hilfe angeboten. Aber du brauchst,
Eine ganze Menge Ressourcen, um äh angebotene Hilfe dann auch zu koordinieren so, ne, weil kriegst heute
angeboten, ich kann ja was Tolles designen, aber nächste Woche, wenn du nicht mal Zeit hast, dir zu sagen, ich ich also ich weiß jetzt ehrlich, was man dir sagen kann. Muss erst mal wieder allen einzeln hinterherlaufen, dann melden sich wieder nicht und dann wird dir was versprochen, dann kommt's wieder nicht, also das ist halt,
das stehen äh also äh so so glücklich wie über jedes Angebot sind, umso leid tut es uns äh das auch immer äh oder häufig ablehnen zu müssen. Das ist nichts böses, sondern dass einfach nur die Erfahrung, dass es wir haben nicht,
Kapazitäten, das zu machen, das ist halt echt traurig, dass man als solche Sachen ja dann noch nicht so ganz automatisieren kann, wie es schön wäre, ähm ja.
Es ist
ist leider auch eben seit oder glücklicherweise seid ihr eben auf dem Niveau, wo ihr euch das auch jetzt nicht mehr erlauben könnt, ne? Das konnten wir irgendwie früher mal machen, da war irgendwie klar, okay das dauert einen Tag länger, äh wenn gerade irgendwie was los ist, aber jetzt
bei bei dem Einfluss, den Netzpolitik Org jetzt schon in den wenigen,
Eigentlich in den letzten Jahren so erlangt hat, ne? Es war immer so, ich war, glaube ich, immer so dieses Fachblock Ding. Klar, da gibt's dieses Fachblock, aber inzwischen ist das völlig normal, dass irgendwie in Bundestagsdebatten andauernd Netzpolitik org schrieb am so und so.
Mal auf Tagesschau DE, ne?
Tagesschau DE. Ja, aber der Einfluss, den den das Blog hier bekommen hat in den in den letzten drei, vier Jahren, wo ich das ja jetzt mehr beobachte, ähm.
Als selber noch mitwirke, das ist schon immer echt beachtlich. Also.
Ja, jetzt gleich, also in vier Minuten müssen wir fertig sein, weil da kommen nämlich Tagesthemen und die machen wahrscheinlich auch damit auf, die ähm heute irgendwie, die wollen die These bringen, dass wir irgendwie das Spiegel der Neuzeit
Spiegel der Neuzeit Sinn, wo ich auch noch irgendwie heute meinte, geht's nicht ein bisschen kleiner, ist bei mir schon ein bisschen unangenehm.
Ja, vor allem, ne, wenn wenn ihr hättet ja, es wäre ja auch schade, wenn euch jetzt irgendwann das das äh das Schicksal des Spiegels ereilen würde, ne.
Wieso, die haben eine äh äh die ich glaube die kriegen das vierfache oder zehnfache von unseren Gehältern Dienstwagen und äh die haben auch schöne Büros direkt neben den Bundestag.
Ich meinte eher inhaltlich.
Faden.
Macht immer weiter.
Spendet, spendet, wir teilen jetzt für Tic Org und genau, euch sind die die regelmäßigen Spenden lieber als die einmaligen Großen, ne? Oder wie.
Naja, also hier äh so am liebsten uns äh jeden Monat eine große Spende. Aber wer sich das nicht leisten kann, was wir
vollkommen verstehen können, ähm ja, also natürlich ist es schön, einmal einhundert Euro zu haben, aber um zu planen, ähm macht es für uns mehr Sinn, diese einhundert Euro vielleicht auf zwölf Monate irgendwie a acht Euro aufzuteilen. Da können wir nämlich jeden Monat besser sehen sozusagen,
können wir jetzt noch, müssen wir jetzt Andrea entlassen oder ähm.
Der lässt sich doch jedes zwar jeden zweiten Winter eh selber und geht irgendwie in die Karibik.
Urlaub ist ja abgesagt.
Chef auf Sponnen gesagt. Aber mir ist wieder eingefallen, was ich sagen wollte. Und es war zur Reichweite. Äh natürlich ist das jetzt in den elf Jahren Existenz von Netzpolitik, als äh nachdem's aus dem ultranischen Thema und diese Netzecke,
raus ist ja eben gewachsen, linear und dann mit so Debatten wie Netzsperren zwotausendneun oder Deutsche Bahnabmahnungen, wann auch immer die war,
Acta. Da waren wir halt immer mal so äh bam äh auch in äh ziemlich großer Reichweite,
aber so unterm Strich, finde ich, geht noch was bei unseren Leserinnen und Lesern. Wir haben eine harte äh Kern-Community, halt so die Netz-Community,
aber die Kritik, die beiden Verfassungsschutzsachen hier aus dem Februar und April um die es jetzt geht, ich bin froh über den, weil ich habe das gepostet und bei dem zweiten Ding im April kam,
halbe Stunde, nachdem ich das gepostet habe und gedacht habe, ey, wochenlange Recherchereien, riesengroßes Thema, wie der Verfassungsschutzeinheits- und Internetüberwachung bam,
Justizminister Maaskin, die Vorratsseitenspeicherung an. Niemand hat sich für den Artikel ja interessiert, ist total untergegangen. Wir haben ja selber deinen Vorratsdatenspeicherung covern und bekämpfen müssen, was wir ja immer noch müssen, ist ja immer noch im Bundestag fest,
und erst jetzt haben die Themen wieder so ein bisschen Aufmerksamkeit erfahren. Jetzt irgendwie gestern,
lange Recherche zur neuen Cyber-Strategie der Bundeswehr veröffentlicht, wieder so ein ultralanges Ding, äh wieder so ein Landesverrat mit äh nur Dienstgebrauch nur für.
Zehn Mal geteilt worden auf.
Und keine Sau interessiert's, weil.
Ja gut, jetzt kam da gestern.
Irgendwie Landes verraten, so man.
Selbst Schuld, hättest du wissen können?
Nee, aber das, das meine ich mit unserer Reichweite, bei anderen Medien ähm den großen Massenmedien, da hat halt jeder einzelne Artikel eine große Reichweite an sich,
Ist das öfter so punktgebunden äh im Netz, wenn's halt irgendwie auf River oder ähm in den Mainstream-Medien ist und noch,
haben wir nicht immer durchschaut, wie diese Mechanismen genau laufen, weil manche Stories, äh wo ich wochenlang dran sitze, denke ich, jetzt müsste aber mal was passieren und da passiert gar nichts. Äh also finde ich,
wir kriegen jetzt bestimmt auch eine größere Stammleserschaft nach all dieser mega Aufmerksamkeit, aber das hatten wir eben schon ein paar Mal mit Deutsche Bahnabmahnungen und so. Ich würde mich freuen,
tatsächlich unsere Inhalte nicht nur für die Kernszene da sind, sondern tatsächlich äh für die Öffentlichkeit.
Wunderbar, Markus wird nervös, wir müssen Tagesthemen gucken,
Ich danke euch. Ich wünsche euch viel Erfolg und ähm wir hoffen dann auch demnächst nochmal auf die Cyberstrategie der Bundeswehr, äh die Aufmerksamkeit des Volks lenken zu.
Wann kommen die Tagesthemen eigentlich morgens.
Morgens kommen die morgens.
Ich habe kein Fleisch, ich kann das nicht anmachen.
Das ist Tagesschau. Also ich sage mal tschüss, ne.
Tschau, vielen Dank.
Internet. Vielen Dank.